dwayne johnson is giving back to his
fans once again because he's the best
surprisingly surprising moviegoers at
two different theaters in los angeles
during a screening of his latest
blockbuster super pet and i think it is
super safe to say that the rock enjoys
this part just as much as the fans
explaining on instagram it has always
been the best part of his job yeah and
you can feel it and my favorite part the
rock even dressed up as his character
crypto the super dog and gave a very
special surprise to one particular
family in the audience take a look it's
super cute we'll see you back here
tomorrow
let's make some noise everyone put your
hands together bc league of super pets
one and only
riptor
this is just really silly
are you okay i see you crying up there
i'm gonna come up there and give you
tissues if you don't sell crying you
guys ready to see super pets
i want to welcome all the families here
if there's one family in particular that
i do want to welcome
where's the hernandez family
oh hey
come on up i was told by your mom and
dad that you guys have had this dream
like all of your lives to get a dog
[Music]
is that right yeah that's right that's
very right i i have something special
for you guys i'll be right back
excuse me mom
i want to welcome your newest family
member this is
quail
you like to hold them